and here not with reaction United States
labor department secretary Eugene Scalia
and it's wonderful to have you here
you've you know the jobless claims
better than everybody maybe before we
get to these questions that we asked for
from viewers that are so good and are
very broad in scope get your initial
thoughts about how you see things today
well today Dana's as we just heard we
reported that 700,000 jobs were lost in
the month of March and then yesterday we
reported that 6.6 million Americans had
filed for unemployment which is a very
large number obviously and so there's a
lot of financial hardship at this moment
as we take the measures that we need to
to defeat the virus it's a difficult
period for many Americans I think the
good news is it's been anticipated in a
sense it's been purposeful right and so
the President Congress have moved
quickly to provide relief ok had that
package there from Brian and he talked
about the dog-walker or the woman who
owned the dog city in business and the
first question that we got from viewers
is I think one that a lot of people have
on their minds and it's something that
secretary monition did talk about
yesterday and that is this as an
independent contractor is there anything
specific that they should do if they
also become unemployed well there are a
few ways that they can look for relief
first of all as secretary mentioned
probably mentioned one really important
part of the cares Act which the
President signed last week is the
provision making payments by the IRS to
most Americans it'll be a $1,500 payment
for dependent children will be another
$500 and so that is financial relief
that's on the way to to most Americans
in terms of people who are independent
contractors and gig workers another
provision of the Kerr's Act makes
unemployment insurance available to them
to you know typically unemployment
insurance is for people with the
an employment relationship employees but
this this bill has relief for them too
and then there also are small business
relief provisions in that act which I
think are really important and what
those provisions do is they say to small
small business that if you come in we'll
give you a loan and that loan will be
forgivable if you keep your employees on
payments yeah it'll be largely
forgivable that that's important to me
because it helps keep that connection
between employer and employee but it's
something that can be available to
people have their own small businesses
and are self-employed let me just ask
you this last question then is there
this is coming from a viewer as well is
there any reassuring message that you
can give to people who are currently
unemployed because of kovat 19 is some
people who are trying to apply for
unemployment insurance they can't even
get through because the phone lines are
you know taken up by other people that
are calling well I think there's no
getting away from the fact that this is
a hard period for most Americans but let
me emphasize these things first part of
what's so jarring about these employment
numbers that we saw today and yesterday
is how strong the economy was just a
month ago we were reporting record highs
just just a month ago and there's
comfort in that I think because we know
that this is an unusual economic
downturn it's not because the
fundamentals in the economy
were weak they're they're actually very
strong the second thing I would
emphasize is discipline now I know
you've been talking to your viewers
about this data but discipline now in
following the public health measures
that are being urged will help keep this
short and so that's so important and let
me say finally that just as this came on
quickly we have a real chance of ending
it quickly because the economy has been
so good because we have in place the
policies of President Trump that made
the economy strong if we're disciplined
now if employers and employees try to
keep that connection through the loan
program I mentioned I think we can pull
out of this more quickly than we have
in other rough economic times certainly
everybody's in the same boat rowing in
the same direction to get that to happen
secretary Scalia thank you